and and we say this every year boy it
seems like more injuries than usual i
feel like it's always the same level but
is it does it does it feel like does it
seem like it's more now that the pads
are on and guys who didn't have off
season workouts who weren't able to work
out like they would in a normal year
does it seem like they are being injured
at a higher rate than they were in the
past
i it does to me it does seem like the
the numbers are higher especially for
these soft tissue injuries that we're
seeing some groins and hamstrings and
quads and things like that calf injuries
i feel like we're seeing more of those i
haven't seen any numbers to to indicate
that and so maybe it's just the fact
that we know they haven't had an off
season so it feels like more maybe this
is still the point where we are and a
lot of these injuries frankly they could
play through if it was the regular
season tyree kill if you'll remember he
had a
similar hamstring thing back in the
season when they played the chargers
they had a bye week the next week but he
didn't miss any time from that and so a
lot of these injuries right now that
they're having they certainly could play
through once the season starts but to me
it does seem like the numbers are more
than what they have been i guess the
good news is we haven't seen a bunch of
stars go down with season ending
injuries to this point i may have just
jinxed it i hope not
but but to me that's probably the good
sign as we haven't seen those big the
robert alford type injuries tj logan
where guys are out for the year we
haven't seen a ton of those
we have a new doctor doom on the program
shireen williams talking about season
ending injuries and jinxing the players
i didn't say it it's not me if it
happens
let me say this though i i i noticed the
word minor a lot with these descriptions
i just wonder how much of that is aimed
at downplaying it so we don't have this
avalanche of concern that there are too
many injuries remember in 2011 the year
of the lockout when there were no
off-season programs the injuries were up
25 that's one of the reasons why the nfl
players association pushed for this
extended ramp up period where
teams didn't get into pads until this
past monday after nearly three weeks of
being in camp at a time when the
preseason games already would be
happening
that's when they finally put the pads on
and now we're seeing guys get injured
but i just think it happens every year i
think we're going to have it every year
and you're right shereen there hasn't
been that
wow
this guy's out for the year holy crap
moment yet
and we both have now officially jinxed
it and and again we talked about this
before that it's one of the things that
this time of year it's that vague
nagging sense that it can happen and and
we've seen time and again that it does
happen but so far they do seem minor
whether they're being downplayed
deliberately or not we'll see when these
guys get back on the field and the
balance that teams are trying to strike
sharing with only 80 guys in camp
you need to have enough healthy players
on the field to get the work in
but you don't want to push guys too hard
so that a minor injury becomes something
that doesn't want to heal or becomes
more than minor and i don't envy these
coaches and their obligation to try to
figure out how to get their teams ready
for what's coming in three weeks
if they're striking that balance or at
least trying to strike that balance
between getting the work in and not
getting their guys injured it reminds me
of that awkward
todd haley hugh jackson conversation
from hard knocks a couple of years ago
do we live in our fears or do we just
throw caution to the wind and get our
team ready even if guys are gonna get
injured
and i think there's a good news bad news
situation with the the preseason too
mike with no preseason this year that's
the good news these guys don't get hurt
we see a lot of these injuries in august
that come during preseason games and
we're not going to have that this year
but again the tackling i think cliff
kingsbury talked about it yesterday you
know how do you get guys ready when
you're not having the contact that you
normally would in the preseason with the
games and trying to balance that so they
also have to balance that
how do you get these guys ready and
practice when they can't do as much as
they normally would in a preseason
because of the lack of preseason games
but at the same time yeah you're not
getting these guys hurt in pre-season
games so it it it's
really a two-edged sword there with with
what's going on with the with the
preseason games but uh they'll have to
figure out a way to arrest these
veterans but at the same time get them
ready keep them healthy and and it's a
delicate balance with some of these guys
who have played 10 years or more to try
to get them ready and keep them healthy
at the same time especially with the
soft tissue injuries
and we're two weeks away from the
rosters being reduced from 80 to 53 and
i've heard talk that some teams may get
to 70 69 that range early with the 53
that'll be on the roster plus the 16
members of the practice squad so that
everyone who is there as we get closer
and closer to cut down day you know the
guys who are going to go the guys at the
bottom of roster know who they are and
once those guys start to feel that it's
coming maybe they start to lose their
covet 19 focus and may do something
stupid on their way out the door don't
be surprised if within the next week or
so some of these teams voluntarily
choose to trim down to the guys who they
know are going to be there or at least
they're sending the message to those
guys that we think you're gonna be here
now with waiver claims and potential
trades and free agents and all the
roster shuffling that happens in early
september who knows but when you get it
down to the number where active roster
plus practice squad equals how many guys
you have shireen that sends a pretty
clear message that everyone who's there
has a pretty damn good chance of being
there for the season and has every
reason to continue
to be very vigilant about keeping the
virus out of the building so i won't be
surprised if teams start dumping those
last 10 guys earlier than then they have
to do it 15 days from today
well and frankly mike you keep that back
into the roster for that fourth
preseason game normally because those
are the guys who play you don't play
your starters in that fourth preseason
game or most teams don't we know some
teams do but most teams don't play
their starters in that last game we
don't have that last game this year
there are no preseason games to worry
about getting those guys in so yeah it
makes sense that you would cut down your
roster sooner and make it clear to those
guys you're going to be here or if
you're not going to be here you may be
here later do the right things now for
covet there's a lot for coaches to worry
about in this month and and this year
frankly
because of covet because of injuries
everything else you know they got two
things really to worry about that are
out of their control which is the
coveted numbers and then the injuries
numbers to go with that which is a
normal year they know they're going to
have the injuries and now they're going
to have guys out with covet too
let me circle back to the tyron smith
injury you know we've just come to take
for granted that the cowboys have a very
good offensive line although it hasn't
been as dominant the last year or two as
it previously was tyron smith banged up
from time to time getting older as we
all are any real concern for tyron smith
or some of these other guys who are
missing time on the offensive line or do
we just continue to take for granted
when it's time to go they'll be ready to
go and they'll be opening holes and
protecting dak prescott and the cowboys
offense will be as potent as it was last
year
no i it's a great point and i had that
on my list of things here you know he's
not yet 30 tyron smith played 10-year
you started when he was 20 years old
came to the league very very young but
he hasn't played a full season since
2015 and to me the back injuries are the
thing that you kind of worry about with
guys like that guys who have played a
decade in this league and he's been one
of the best offensive tackles in
football for a really long time now but
even though he's not yet 30 those back
injuries don't go away and and we've
seen it with a lot of guys and they end
up retiring because that back just
doesn't get any better that's what i
worry about with him yes i think the
injuries have started to pile up on
tyron smith i think the cowboys do have
to start thinking and have started
thinking over the last couple drafts you
can tell that they're kept moving along
that offensive line looking at well
we're going to have to make some
think about making some changes here if
thing if worse comes to worse and tyron
smith does end his career with an injury
at some point but
uh yeah so you do worry about him a
little bit lyle collins was already out
of practice before the car crashed so
they're a little thin in that offensive
line and then with travis frederick
retiring so i don't know that that
offensive line is going to in dallas is
going to look quite like we've seen it
look over the past few years the cowboys
certainly hope it is
tyron smith doesn't turn 30 until
december 12th so he played most of his
rookie season at the age of 20. and that
happens from time to time and that's the
counter to the argument that phony fake
argument don't get me started the nfl
and the nfl pa come together to ensure
that college football will have the
benefit of free labor for three years by
saying these guys are too young to
compete with men well tyron smith at age
20 competed with men for nearly a full
season before he turned 21 so once guys
are ready they're ready tyron smith was
ready and he's been getting it done for
nearly a decade and here's hoping that
back holds up and he can continue to
keep doing it for another decade in the
nfl
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports